what advice do you have for a young man
in his 20s
make a plan look at what you're
interested in
get disciplined about something allow
for the possibility that you have
something
important to contribute to the world and
that the world would be a lesser place
without that contribution
don't be afraid of taking on
responsibility you're so
it's where you find what sustains you in
your life
you can take on too much responsibility
you you have to be cautious in that
regard but
that's a less common problem than not
taking on enough
a lot of the things that people regard
as traps are actually
the means to their life you know often
young people
are afraid of commitment for example in
the context of a romantic relationship
and
because they feel that that's going to
interfere with their pursuit of
something more valuable but that's just
not the case is you're not going to find
something more valuable in your life
than a committed relationship with
someone that you love
that sustains itself across time and
that in all likelihood
produces children that's life and
there may be people for whom
avoiding that is the better route but
those people are very rare and
you need a real reason to assume that
you're one of those people
and hopefully for you you're not um
you know i've had a very good career a
very meaningful career
in multiple dimensions and it's still
been the case for me that the most
important part of my life
has been my intimate relationship with
my wife and my
and my family so don't be afraid of that
or be afraid of it but don't let that
stop you from from pursuing it